one time I was in Denver and I ate a
burrito from a convenience store
I was definitely still frozen one time I
ate a club sandwich that was still in
the room service tray in that hotel
hallway oh and just about any city you
travel to there are plenty of late-night
eats to choose from so today from
American Express Studios we're showing
you some of our favorite local eats and
hopefully making your next 2 a.m.
decision a little easier
all right guys pay attention because
we're gonna move fast card to hand on
Columbia nothing like a pile of
everything to end the night Reykjavik
Iceland hot dog with onions and romola
Montreal Canada
poutine Tokyo Japan poor crop Prague
Czech Republic it's amaz NEC it curry
Wurst
more like curry best welcome to Budapest
here's the plate of long gush we can go
on for days probably weeks but for now
you got a good starting point for your
next late-night adventure
ever have an amazing late-night meal
while traveling let us know leave a
comment below
you